Cannibalism is common in the animal kingdom,
but that’s not what you’re seeing now.
These are two different species of nematodes:
the predator is P. pacificus, and
its prey is C. elegans.
Some hungry pacificus don’t stop with different
species though.
They also eat the larva of their own species–
just a different strain.
This means pacificus nematodes actually are
cannibals--they eat nematodes of their own
species, but avoid their close relatives.
Researchers wanted to know how these nematodes
avoid feasting on their family.
To the human eye, they aren’t easy to tell apart.
How do the nematodes do it?
The researchers started with scent.
They thought the worms might be emitting a
pheremone that allows them to recognize each other.
But when they blended the scent of pacificus
with another species, the cannibal worms still
preyed only on nematodes outside their family.
So it wasn’t the smell.
It must have been a different signal.
To find this self-recognition signal, researchers
decided to look for genetic differences between
different strains of the pacifius nematode.
They identified a region within the genome
associated with killing behavior, then used
CRIPSR-Cas9 to find the gene associated with
self-recognition .
When this sequence was changed through gene
editing, the pacificus began to cannibalize
its own family.
The gene, dubbed SELF-1, is expressed in the
outermost layer of the nematode’s skin–right
where it needs to be for tactile sensing.
And because each strain has a unique version,
it might serve as a kind of “calling card”
for the identity of the nematode.
More research could help scientists understand
how the nematodes detect this signal through touch.
It could also shed light on the evolutionary
path that these divergent strains took.
And as the scientists better understand how
this works in nematodes, they hope it will
give them insight into other self-recognition systems–
like those that keep mammalian babies’
strange cells safe inside their mothers.